hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds I'm a property investor I make a
lot of money in property but I also
absolutely love vlogging the journey
teaching people how to make money and
how to become financially free in
property every Sunday at 7 p.m. I like
to give an opportunity to answer my fans
questions and issues and niggling
problems so this week I've put together
a list of last week's questions and
comments if you have questions for me
comment them below in the comments and
I'll do my best to answer them next week
but right now here are the ones that
we've had selected our Manny Morris has
said I cannot wrap my head around
refinancing someone please help and then
also there's been quite a few questions
about refinancing as well like care and
sell we said how do I go about
refinancing in the first six months of
owning a bike select let me talk a
little bit about what we financing is
and then I'll go on to answer your
question as well Karen say I want to buy
this is a house and I want to buy it
before you buy the house you can borrow
money from the bank and we call this
money and mortgage to buy the house
because we're like geez I can't afford
that I can't afford to I can't afford a
hundred thousand pound to buy this house
so typically you can borrow
we've buy to that up to about eighty
percent of the value of the house so in
this occasion this house is a hundred
thousand pounds I want to buy it I can't
afford to buy it buy it so I'll put some
of my own money down maybe twenty
thousand pounds and I'll borrow 80,000
pounds now the bank isn't just gonna
give you eighty thousand pounds and just
say I trust you to buy this house here's
the 80 grand have fun they all want to
know that you're actually going to be
buying this house and they're gonna they
gonna check you out they're gonna check
the house out they're gonna check the
house is actually worth a hundred
thousand pounds and when they give you
the 80 thousand pound alone which is
debt but it's good debt it's on a house
as long as the house is good when they
give you the 80 thousand pounds what
they're gonna say is they're gonna say
that they want a charge on this house
meaning that if you just say thanks for
the money I'm not going to pay you back
now they can take this from you so you
own the house is in your name but they
are the charge on it so if you don't
give them their money back in the agreed
way then then they're gonna take you
from you that is a mortgage now a
mortgage is typically over like a 3035
year term the interest rates are about
three percent if you can't make money on
borrowing and paying back just three
percent interest and you can't make
money then you really suck because three
percent is so that means you borrow you
borrow a hundred grams and you're gonna
be paying three grand a year which is
what how much are most like two hundred
eighty pound a month like the rents can
there be a lot more than that that's
what I'm always just now what is a
refinance how does that work a refinance
is where you get a mortgage on a
property but you do it after you bought
the house you could buy the house for
instance you can bite in cash you can
buy this with your own money I'll buy
this house for a hundred grand and then
the house maybe goes up in value and it
becomes worth 150 grand it's gone up in
value so you've made fifty thousand
pounds in equity the house is now worth
more but you only bought it for 100 at
this point you go to the bank and you
say hey I've got this house it's worth
150 thousand I bought it for a hundred
but it's gone up since net I did a bit
of work on it the economy's lifted it's
gone up can you please lend me 80
percent or 75 percent whatever you can
get please can you lend me 80 percent of
the value of the purchase price so now
they're gonna give you 80 percent of the
value of this house they're gonna give
you 80 percent of which you can you can
you can use that money to buy more
houses so as long as they have the
charge on the property and as long as as
long as they're not gonna over leverage
would be if they said and this is what
the banks would in 2006 sure man you can
have a hundred percent mortgage in fact
you can have one hundred and twenty-five
percent mortgage they were going crazy
so that's what it is so to answer your
question what's a refinance a refinance
would be and this is always a property
investor that you can you can maximize
off of this what you can do is you can
say I'll buy this house a bio for 80
grand
and I'll get a a bridging loan a
bridging loan is just it's not it's not
really a mortgage it's just like a
short-term loan which is used for
property usually so you can buy it for
80 thousand pounds and then add value to
it or wait for the property go up in
value and then you just get a new
mortgage on it and then they'll lend
against the property against equity on
the property so that is one of this I
hope that answers the question from
Armani about you can't wrap your head
around refinancing to answer Karen's
property how do I go about refinancing
in the first six months of owning it
depends on if you bought it and you've
got a mortgage on it and you're already
leveraged why do you want to refinance
it you can only get a new mortgage on it
if you've lifted the value there's
otherwise there's no point getting the
new mortgage on it there was a six month
rule which said that you you have to
wait six months so if you buy it for
cash and then you add value to it you've
got to wait six months of owning it
before you can get a mortgage on the
house they've actually scrapped that
rule there's some lenders now kempt
reliance you can buy a house on a
bridging loan you can add value to it
and you can refinance it immediately
like the next day as soon as the values
been added there's no there's no
six-month rule so can rely on check them
out great lender I use camera loans
quite a lot so I hope that clears that
up
you've got more questions on that
comment below and I might even do a
whole video around bridging loans maybe
sometime soon if that helps okay next
as a deal sorcerer where do you find
investors if you find good enough deals
the investors will begin to find you
number one scale as a property
entrepreneur or a property investor is
just find good deals there's no point
understanding about financing and
bridging and all this you can you can
understand everything but unless you can
actually find a property deal that's
good it's not going to help so first
thing I have says before you even try
and find investors just find good deals
where do I find investors I put myself
out there man I do a video on YouTube
every single day I do not have a problem
finding investors I don't actually
package and sell property deals I don't
do that anymore I used to do it but I
don't do it anymore because I don't want
to compete with my students put yourself
out there tell the world that you're a
property investor go to networking
events come on training programs
and network on social media don't be
selling though don't be silly
like always serve before you sell you
know but make sure if you're trying to
hook up an investor with an investment
make sure you get payment upfront or
make them sign an NDA and non-disclosure
agreement because investors they'll
always try and cut you out the deal so I
hope that helps that was from the road
to financial freedom that was the
question so advance is your question
and I hope that you are closer to your
road to financial freedom as a result my
answer okay who bun next Lauren Co binco
hey Samuel thanks for the great videos
keep up the good work I'm thinking of
investing in property with my brother
and dad and Paulie down money together
hopefully build a portfolio quickly what
strategy would you use in this case also
does this mean we would be best to use a
limited company to split profits firstly
it's really important that equal reward
equal risk so if you're all put in the
same amount of money in the pot then
then fine make sure that you have really
clear understandings exit strategies
have a contract even with your family
sometimes you can think I don't need a
contract because we trust each other
it's not about trust
it's about clarity so it's none of this
oh you said this so so have a clear
agreement think of all the different
scenarios that could go wrong write them
down and do if this happens then we
decide this would then we would then do
this decisions are always better made in
the cold light of day before any
problems have arisen in regards to you
would you be better to use a limited
company yeah absolutely
again depending on what kind of joint
venture you want to set up it could be
that you set up a like one company where
you all come on as shareholders and
you're kind of a third equal equal
profits you put money in the pot and
then you start growing you know just
just just make sure you get legal advice
accountant and a solicitor to make sure
that you doing it properly but yeah
you're on the right page you know put
money together club together and also as
well just because you've joined a
business together and you've and you've
started buying houses you need to also
be clear that doesn't necessarily mean
that you can
ever buy houses with your brother and
dad it could be that you say look we're
gonna put 50 grand in each and then with
that money
strategy us which started you'll be the
best depends how much money you've got
my favorite strategy right now is buying
a house adding value to it and then we
financing it I love doing that because
you can just keep going recycling your
money again and again hence how much
money you got depends on your goals if
you've only got five grand each and you
want to all quit your jobs within the
next three weeks then my advice will be
very different then I'm gonna do some
rent to serviced accommodation deals if
you've got 50 grand each and you want to
build wealth then I'd say buy a house
maybe split it up refurb it so it really
just depends but also get the training
like honestly I can't even stress that
enough the amount of people that do bad
deals lose money get bad builders just
because I've not been in the right
environment and I've not got the proper
training so I would always encourage get
training and I'm gonna say training I'm
not necessarily just talking about books
and podcasts and CDs I'm talking about
get in the right environment and that's
why I won't try any programs because I'm
a real believer the people should people
learn well together
and when you're in environment where
you're growing and you're learning and
you do deals together in a safe way
you're just gonna go so much further so
I hope that helped the last question
this is Jay W hi Samuel can you get into
property based in London of course you
can seems difficult as cheap investment
opportunities are all in the north
depends what you want yeah you're gonna
struggle to get cheap investment
opportunity in London unless you buy
shed because London's really expensive
but then although little is expensive it
doesn't mean that there aren't
opportunities there because London's the
capital city you know so there's a lot
of opportunities in London there's a lot
of investments there there's a lot of
development opportunities the rents are
very high you can make money anywhere
you've just got a workout what do you
know what do you want how much money
have you got to play with but what I
would say is there's nothing wrong with
living in London I'm living in London
now we're just in the process of moving
all our stuff over we're moving to
Buckingham share our offices we live in
London but that doesn't mean that all my
investments are gonna be in London
people that think they have to only buy
where they live are very narrow minded
and if you think that you have to buy
where you live
I would just question why why do you
have to buy where you live is it are you
really doing it because you feel that if
the house was far away and then there
was a problem you wouldn't be able to
get involved but my point would be well
you shouldn't be getting involved in any
way you should be buying houses that are
going to give you a lot of money a good
return on investment and you should be
having power team in place so that it's
passive income for you it's passive so
buy anywhere but just make sure that the
figures stack up and you have a good
power team in place guys thank you for
your great questions
I'm sure you've got more questions
comment them below because I love
answering them I love seeing you succeed
your success is my oxygen so if you do
go on to succeed as a result of my
training remember it be YouTube videos
or the courses that we run please let me
know because I'd like to invite you to
come down to the offices and have an
interview with you on winners Wednesday
so smash that like button
get yourself subscribed if you're not
already it's amazing how many people
watch the videos and aren't subscribed
it's nuts you don't want to miss videos
get subscribed smash the notification
button so you don't miss a video and
I'll see you next time peace out
[Music]
[Music]